Salut,
c’est Romain,
de 1000 idées de culture générale.
J’ai deux petites choses importantes
à vous dire
avant que la vidéo ne commence.
PREMIÈRE CHOSE :
ne regardez PAS
la vidéo
comme ça,
avec du pop-corn.
Si vous voulez RETENIR
ce que vous allez apprendre
dans cette vidéo,
vous DEVEZ
prendre des notes.
Les études sur la mémorisation
ne laissent AUCUNE PLACE
au doute :
NE PAS PRENDRE
DE NOTES
ÉGALE
OUBLIER.
Donc faites-moi plaisir :
ouvrez une application
comme Google Docs
ou Evernote,
et NOTEZ
ce qui est essentiel pour vous
au fur et à mesure.
SECONDE CHOSE
que je dois vous dire :
la vidéo que vous allez regarder
est extraite de ma formation
de culture générale
qui s’appelle
« Culture Express ».
C’est une formation qui permet
d’acquérir RAPIDEMENT
une bonne culture générale,
SANS
se prendre la tête,
sans avoir à lire
ni à réfléchir.
Elle couvre tous les domaines
de la culture générale :
elle permet de maîtriser
les connaissances essentielles
sur l’histoire de l’humanité,
sur l’histoire de France,
en économie,
en science politique,
en psychologie,
en science,
en littérature,
en art,
en religion,
ET ENFIN...
...en philosophie
— eh oui,
c’est important
la philo.
Si ça vous intéresse,
jetez-y un coup d’œil,
soit en cliquant
sur le lien qui apparaît maintenant
en haut à droite de la vidéo,
soit en cliquant
sur celui qui est dans la description
de cette vidéo.
Voilà voilà,
je vous ai dit
ce que je voulais vous dire.
Maintenant
je vous laisse regarder la vidéo.
Concentrez-vous,
préparez-vous
à prendre des notes,
et puis n’hésitez pas à m’écrire
dans les commentaires.
Et moi je vous dis :
à la prochaine !
«
La philosophie, c’est le bon conseil.
» — Sénèque, Lettres à Lucilius
Cette question, je me la suis posée pendant
longtemps. En classe de terminale, déjà,
je trouvais étrange que la prof ne nous dise pas
clairement ce qu’est « la philosophie », et ce à
quoi elle sert. J’étais d’autant plus embarrassé
de ne pas disposer d’éléments de réponse efficaces
que des sujets de dissertation portaient
sur la question (par exemple, « Philosopher,
est-ce apprendre à mourir ? »).
J’ai finalement pris la mesure de
cette question lorsque j’ai commencé de lire
des histoires de la philosophie. En bref,
la réponse dépend des époques, des contextes
politiques et idéologiques — et bien sûr
des « philosophes » eux-mêmes. La définition de
la philosophie, de sa finalité et de son champ
d’investigation, sont aussi un enjeu de pouvoir,
car il s’agit de désigner les détenteurs légitimes
d’une autorité intellectuelle.
Dans cette leçon, je vais
répondre aux questions suivantes :
* Comment définir la philosophie ?
* D’où vient la philosophie ?
* Quelles sont les branches de la philosophie ?
* Qui sont les philosophes ?
* Que reproche-t-on à la philosophie ?
Comment définir la philosophie ?
Il n’est pas simple de définir la
philosophie, car le sens du mot
a évolué au cours de l’histoire.
Que signifie dans l’absolu
le mot « philosophie » ?
Quelqu’un qui ne s’est jamais intéressé
à la discipline intellectuelle qu’est la
philosophie peut pourtant se servir du nom
commun « philosophie ». S’il est économe,
il peut affirmer : « ma philosophie, c’est
de n’acheter que le nécessaire ». Il veut
dire par-là qu’il a une ligne de conduite en
matière de dépenses. C’est dans ce même sens
qu’il m’arrive de rappeler à mes élèves ma «
philosophie » de la simplicité, fondée sur le
constat que les processus les plus simples sont
ceux qui ont le plus de chances de réussir.
Cet usage courant dérive bien du
sens strict du mot « philosophie ».
La philosophie, c’est étymologiquement
l’amour de la sagesse. En effet,
le verbe grec philein signifie « aimer »,
et le nom sophia signifie « la sagesse ».
« Le plus ancien nom de la
philosophie fut sagesse.
» — Charles Renouvier, Manuel de philosophie
D’après Diogène Laërce, c’est Pythagore qui a
inventé le mot au VIe siècle avant J.-C. dans
une discussion avec le tyran Léon de Sicyone.
Ce néologisme lui a servi à distinguer, d’une
part, la sagesse accomplie de Dieu, et d’autre
part l’homme qui vise et chérit la sagesse.
Mais qu’est-ce que la sagesse ? Issu du verbe
latin sapere, « avoir du discernement
», le terme désigne la qualité d’une
personne qui prend de bonnes décisions grâce
au raisonnement et à l’expérience. On associe
souvent la sagesse à la prudence, qui était la
plus grande vertu pour les philosophes antiques
et chrétiens. On retrouve donc bien l’idée
de l’usage courant, la ligne de conduite.
Comment le sens du mot «
philosophie » a-t-il évolué ?
Au départ, le terme est fidèle à son étymologie
: la philosophie est l’amour de la sagesse.
Pour expliquer cette définition, Pythagore compare
la vie à une de ces grandes foires où l’on venait
de toute la Grèce, les uns pour concourir dans
les jeux, les autres pour vendre et pour acheter,
d’autres enfin pour le seul plaisir d’en
voir le spectacle. Il divise alors les
hommes en 2 catégories : 1° ceux qui ont
des affaires, et 2° ceux qui n’en ont pas.
« Dans la vie, les uns naissent esclaves et
chassent gloire et richesses ; les autres naissent
philosophes et chassent la vérité. » — Pythagore
Dans cette allégorie, la philosophie est aussi
la quête du savoir nécessaire
à la sagesse. C’est en ce sens
que Socrate dit qu’il faut se connaître soi-même.
De là, le mot en vient à désigner le savoir
tout court. Platon, qui utilise beaucoup le
mot « philosophie », en étend le sens à une forme
de savoir assez large, mais pas totalisante — les
mathématiques et l’histoire, par exemple,
n’en font pas partie. Son disciple Aristote,
lui, étend ce sens à l’ensemble du savoir
rationnel, c’est-à-dire qu’à ses yeux la
philosophie équivaut à la science elle-même.
« Le philosophe est celui qui possède la
totalité du savoir dans la mesure du
possible. » — Aristote, Métaphysique
Ensuite, le mot évolue en se
distinguant d’autres mots :
* Dans les premiers siècles du Ier millénaire,
les Pères de l’Église distinguent la philosophie
de la religion, alors qu’auparavant les
questions divines pouvaient entrer dans
le champ d’investigation du philosophe.
Certains dialogues de Platon traitent
par exemple de l’utilité de la piété religieuse.
* La définition d’Aristote perdure jusqu’à la fin
du XVIIIe siècle, où la philosophie se distingue
enfin de la science. Les célèbres scientifiques
des Lumières sont des spécialistes qui travaillent
déjà dans l’esprit de la science moderne, tandis
que ceux qu’on appelle alors « les philosophes »
sont des écrivains partisans de la raison, plus ou
moins hostiles aux institutions religieuses.
« Philosophe, amateur de la sagesse,
c’est-à-dire de la vérité. » —
Voltaire, Dictionnaire philosophique
Enfin, c’est également à partir de cette
période qu’apparaissent des expressions
telles que « philosophie de la religion »,
« philosophie du droit », « philosophie de
l’art », ou encore « philosophie des sciences
». L’emploi du mot « philosophie » signifie
que ces nouvelles spécialités intellectuelles
étudient les principes directeurs implicites
sur lesquelles reposent les disciplines ainsi que
le rapport de ces principes à l’esprit humain.
D’où vient la philosophie ?
La philosophie qui naît en Grèce au
VIe siècle avant J.-C. a à la fois des origines
historiques et des racines intellectuelles.
Quelle est l’origine
historique de la philosophie ?
Les idées ne naissent ex nihilo. Nous savons
comment elles naissent : un homme découvre
certaines idées en rencontrant d’autres hommes
; il les fait siennes, les combine avec d’autres
idées ; puis il les diffuse à son tour.
Ce n’est donc pas le fruit du hasard si la
philosophie naît en Grêce. Elle émerge sur
les côtes ioniennes — donc pas au centre
du pays — dans des villes qui étaient plus
prospères et plus développées, mais surtout…
qui avaient été en contact par d’autres cultures,
notamment les civilisations égyptienne et perse.
« L’activité philosophique, certains disent
qu’elle tient son origine des Barbares.
» — Diogène Laërce, Vies et doctrines des
philosophes illustres, Diogène Laërce
Vous pouvez retenir 2 origines
historiques principales.
1° Les marges perses sont, d’après
Aristote, la source la plus lointaine.
Un mage perse est à l’origine un disciple de
Zoroastre, le prophète fondateur du zoroastrisme,
puis il a le statut de prêtre officiel
perse. Il est, aux yeux des Grecs,
un spécialiste de magie, c’est-à-dire l’art
de produire des phénomènes sortant du cours
ordinaire de la nature, et d’astrologie.
Les mages perses auraient inspiré d’autres
inspirateurs « barbares » de la philosophie
grecque : les « chaldéens » chez les Babyloniens
ou les Assyriens, les « gymnosophistes » chez les
Indiens, ou encore les druides celtes et gaulois.
2° Les prêtres égyptiens sont
une source plus récente.
Les échanges intellectuels avec l’Égypte
continuent même après la naissance de la
philosophie au VIe siècle av. J.-C. C’était à
l’époque un pays mystérieux et fascinant, la plus
brillante civilisation du monde méditerranéen.
Les jeunes Grecs fortunés avaient coutume de s’y
rendre parce qu’ils considéraient ce voyage comme
partie intégrante de leur initiation à la vie
(la traversée ne coûtait même que 2 drachmes).
C’était une tradition philosophique de passer dans
la ville sacerdotale d'Héliopolis, pour méditer
sur la mort en observant les rituels funéraires et
le culte des morts. Solon, Pythagore, Hérodote, ou
encore Démocrite auraient suivi cette tradition.
On raconte que Platon se serait rendu
en Égypte après la mort de Socrate.
Quelles sont les racines
intellectuelles de la philosophie ?
Pour simplifier, on peut distinguer
2 racines intellectuelles.
1° La philosophie vient d’abord
de la religion, ou la théologie.
Cette racine est évidente dans
les origines historiques de la
philosophie grecque : les mages perses et
les prêtres égyptiens sont des religieux.
D’après Diogène Laërce, les mages ne
se contentaient pas d’exécuter les
rituels religieux. Ils élaboraient aussi un
discours sophistiqué, théologique bien sûr,
mais plus généralement métaphysique, c’est-à-dire
qu’ils voulaient découvrir les essences des choses
(par opposition aux apparences). Les philosophes
grecs, eux aussi, spéculent sur la divinité et
sur la nature ultime de la réalité, et ils
le font probablement à partir des idées des
mages perses et des prêtres égyptiens.
« Les Mages s’expriment au sujet de
l’essence et de l’origine des dieux.
» — Diogène Laërce, Vies et doctrines
des philosophes illustres, Diogène Laërce
La racine religieuse se retrouve également
dans la dimension spirituelle, théorique mais
aussi pratique, de la philosophie grecque. Le
rapport à la mort, par exemple, vient peut-être
des gymnosophistes indiens, lesquels, parce
qu’ils méprisaient la douleur, se suicidaient
volontiers en s’immolant. Plus généralement,
les exercices spirituels pratiqués dans les
écoles philosophiques (méditation, respiration,
abstinence, endurance, etc.) semblent inspirés
par les traditions spirituelles orientales.
2° La philosophie vient ensuite de la science.
Par « science », j’entends les disciplines
qui produisent les connaissances les
plus fiables, qu’on appelle parfois
les sciences « exactes », ou « dures ».
Les philosophes grecs ont notamment repris
la tradition scientifique des Égyptiens,
qui auraient découvert la géométrie,
l’arithmétique et l’astronomie. Pythagore,
qui est à l’origine des théorèmes que vous
avez appris au collège, a par exemple effectué
des voyages initiatiques en Égypte, en Chaldée,
et en Perse. Est-ce là qu’il s’est formé
aux mathématiques ? C’est fort probable.
« Comme il était jeune et avide de savoir, il
voyagea hors de sa patrie, et fut initié à tous
les mystères, aussi bien grecs que barbares. » —
Diogène Laërce, Vies et doctrines des philosophes
illustres, Diogène Laërce
L’affinité entre la science,
en particulier les mathématiques, et la
philosophie perdurera dans l’histoire de
la philosophie. Dans l’Antiquité, les disciples
font des maths dans les écoles philosophiques,
au point que Platon fait graver à l’entrée de la
sienne, l’Académie, « Que nul n’entre ici s’il
n’est géomètre ». Au XVIIe siècle, Descartes
et Pascal sont d’éminents mathématiciens.
Au XXe siècle, Bertrand Russell, qui a écrit
une histoire de la philosophie de référence,
considère comme Platon que les mathématiques
sont un indispensable prélude à la philosophie.
Quelles sont les branches de la philosophie ?
La philosophie est une discipline intellectuelle
très vaste, en lien avec beaucoup d’autres,
c’est pourquoi on la subdivise en branches.
Quelles sont les grandes
orientations de la philosophie ?
Avant de détailler les sous-disciplines en
lesquelles ont subdivise traditionnellement la
philosophie, je veux évoquer les grandes manières
de la comprendre et de la pratiquer. En effet, les
philosophes eux-mêmes ne voient pas la même chose
dans la philosophie. Cela dépend des époques,
des contextes, et des personnes.
Pour faire simple, on peut opposer
2 manières de comprendre la philosophie :
1. la philosophie comme quête du bonheur ;
2. la philosophie comme quête de la vérité.
« La philosophie enseigne à agir, non à
parler. » — Sénèque, Lettres à Lucilius
Bien sûr, les deux conceptions ne sont
pas incompatibles. Tel philosophe adhère
surtout à la première, tel autre plutôt
à la seconde. Et comme je l’ai expliqué à
propos de la définition de la philosophie,
la quête du bonheur présuppose une quête de la
vérité sur la manière d’accéder au bonheur.
Les deux tendances alternent le long des
siècles. La philosophie désigne tantôt un
champ d’investigation métaphysique, tantôt un
modèle de sagesse à imiter. Voici la logique
de l’alternance : la théorie atteint une certaine
profondeur ; elle est ensuite commentée, reprise
et diffusée ; puis l’alternance se produit.
«
À l’origine comme aujourd’hui, c’est l’étonnement
et l’admiration qui conduisirent les hommes à
la philosophie. » — Aristote, Métaphysique
Après Aristote, par exemple, la philosophie
se vide de son contenu dans la Grèce
d’après Alexandre le Grand avec les
écoles épicurienne et stoïcienne. Les idées et
le discours ne disparaissent pas pour autant,
mais c’est la sérénité du sage qui devient la
finalité de l’activité philosophique. Certains
philosophes comme Descartes, apôtre du détachement
stoïcien en même temps que du doute scientifique,
combinent les deux conceptions.
Quelles sont les branches
précises de la philosophie ?
Les Anciens distinguaient 3 parties
dans la philosophie. La « physique » (à ne pas
confondre avec la science moderne), tout d’abord,
étudie le monde et les êtres qu’il contient.
Ensuite, l’éthique, qui commencera avec Socrate,
comprend les réflexions sur la vie et les
affaires des hommes. Enfin, la dialectique
consiste en l’étude des raisonnements.
Ils opposaient également les philosophes
dogmatiques, d’une part, qui échafaudent
un système d’interprétation du monde ; et
les philosophes sceptiques,
d’autre part, qui mettent en
évidence les illusions dont souffrent les hommes.
Ces classifications antiques peuvent être utiles,
mais elles sont désuètes.
On subdivise aujourd’hui
la philosophie en 5 branches :
1. la logique est l’étude de la méthode
idéale de pensée et de recherche ;
2. l’esthétique est l’étude de
la forme idéale, ou de la beauté ;
3. l’éthique est l’étude de la conduite idéale ;
4. la politique est l’étude de
l’organisation sociale idéale ;
5. la métaphysique est l’étude
de la réalité ultime des choses.
Les philosophes qui voient la philosophie comme
la quête de la vérité ultime ont tendance à la
réduire à la métaphysique. D’ailleurs, le mot
« métaphysique » est dans le titre de certains
chefs d’œuvres, comme la Métaphysique d’Aristote,
ou les Méditations métaphysiques de Descartes.
« La métaphysique est le roman
de l’esprit. » — Voltaire
Cette branche de la philosophie
peut s’intéresser à 3 objets :
1. la matière, ce qui donne l’ontologie ;
2. l’esprit, ce qui donne
la philosophie psychologique ;
3. l’interaction entre l’esprit et la matière,
ce qui donne l’épistémologie.
Qui sont les philosophes ?
Comment devient-on philosophe ?
Dans l’Antiquité, 3 ingrédient sont
nécessaires pour devenir philosophe :
1. L’aisance financière. La philosophie
n’est pas une activité économique — en tout cas
au début — et il peut être nécessaire de payer
un professeur. C’est la raison pour laquelle la
grande majorité des philosophes sont des « fils
de bonne famille » qui n’ont pas besoin
de se soucier du vivre et du couvert.
2. Un maître. On devient philosophe en devenant
le disciple d’un maître, généralement dans le
cadre d’une école. Cela implique un certain mode
de vie communautaire : les membres d’une même
école vivent ensemble à l’écart de la cité
; ils font les mêmes activités (notamment
écouter le maître) ; se déplacent ensemble dans
la cité, voyagent ensemble à l’extérieur ; suivent
parfois le même régime alimentaire.
3. Une « œuvre ». À partir de l’époque
de Platon, les philosophes peuvent diffuser
leurs idées à l’écrit grâce aux volumens,
des copies sur des rouleaux de papyrus (qui
sont enroulés autour d’un support de bois).
Leurs productions leur permettent de gagner
la reconnaissance des autres philosophes.
Primum vivere deinde philosophari (« Vivre
d’abord, puis philosopher. ») — Hobbes
Il existe bien sûr des exceptions. Socrate,
par exemple, subvenait à ses besoins et à
ceux de sa famille grâce à l’aide financière
de ses riches amis. Vous savez peut-être aussi
qu’il n’a rien écrit. Je pense aussi à
Cléanthe, le n°2 de l’école stoïcienne,
qui était un boxeur très pauvre. Arrivé à
Athènes avec seulement 4 drachmes en poche,
il est devenu célèbre pour
son acharnement au travail.
Voici maintenant les 3 ingrédients
nécessaires dans notre contexte moderne :
1. Un parcours académique. Un philosophe a souvent
fait des études supérieures à l’université,
où il a décroché un diplôme de philosophie (j’ai
par exemple un Master 2 de philosophie de la
Sorbonne [mais je ne suis pas un philosophe]) ou
dans une discipline en lien avec la philosophie.
Il travaille parfois encore dans le monde
académique, comme enseignant ou chercheur.
2. La consécration. Un philosophe « professionnel
» consacre la majeure partie de son temps et de
son énergie à la philosophie. Par exemple,
un médecin qui aime lire des ouvrages
philosophiques et écrit quelques articles
de temps en temps ne mérite probablement
pas d’être qualifié de « philosophe ».
3. Une « œuvre ». Comme dans l’Antiquité,
les philosophes modernes sont d’autant plus
reconnus comme tels qu’ils produisent du contenu
philosophique, à destination de leurs pairs ou
du public général. Ils ont donc intérêt à publier
des articles, à contribuer à des ouvrages —
mais le graal, c’est de publier un essai.
Il est difficile de trouver des exceptions.
Il est très rare que les philosophes modernes
n’aient aucune formation académique. L’exemple
de Rousseau, qui était un pur autodidacte,
me paraît unique en son genre. De même, à ma
connaissance, aucun philosophe de l’ère moderne
n’a été un dilettante, ou n’a rien produit.
Qui sont les philosophes vivants
les plus importants ?
Malgré mes efforts pour être
le plus objectif possible, ma sélection est
bien évidemment biaisée. N’hésitez donc pas
à en discuter dans les commentaires.
Je prévois aussi de la faire évoluer,
même si le nombre de noms doit rester limité.
Voici les philosophes français vivants
les plus importants :
* Edgar Morin (né en 1921) est
à la fois sociologue et philosophe. Son idée
majeure est probablement celle de la pensée
complexe : il s’agit d’une forme de pensée qui
accepte les imbrications de toutes les disciplines
intellectuelles et qui autorise l’esprit humain à
passer de l’une à l’autre. La pensée d’Edgar Morin
est influente en Amérique latine et en Asie.
* Alain Badiou (né en 1937) est un pur produit de
l’École normale supérieure. Engagé politiquement
à l’extrême-gauche, il se réclame du marxisme,
et plusieurs de ses ouvrages cherchent à
réhabiliter l’idée communiste. Le grand public
le découvre en 2007 avec son pamphlet contre
le nouveau président de la République, De quoi
Sarkozy est-il le nom ?. Il est le philosophe
français le plus traduit dans le monde.
* Jacques Bouveresse (né en 1940) est un
philosophe rationaliste, professeur au
Collège de France. Il défend les valeurs de la
clarté, de la précision et de la mesure, c’est
pourquoi il dénonce l’abus de concepts techniques
pour produire de l’autorité intellectuelle. Dans
Prodiges et vertiges de l'analogie, il met à
l’index le prétendu « droit à la métaphore » qui
sert à défendre des idées fallacieuses.
* Marcel Gauchet (né en 1946),
que j’ai eu la chance d’écouter à l’EHESS, est un
philosophe souvent catalogué comme conservateur.
Son idée majeure est probablement
celle du désenchantement du monde,
qui signifie que la religion ne structure plus
la société. Il est aussi à l’origine du concept
de « fracture sociale », sur lequel Jacques
Chirac bâtira sa campagne victorieuse de 1995.
* Pierre Manent (né en 1949), que j’ai
également eu la chance d’écouter à l’EHESS,
est un philosophe libéral. Beaucoup d’étudiants
connaissent d’ailleurs son Histoire intellectuelle
du libéralisme. Il est aussi connu comme le
disciple et héritier intellectuel de Raymond
Aron, qu’il assistait au Collège de France.
* Michel Onfray (né en 1959) est probablement le
philosophe le plus médiatique, et par conséquent
— ceci explique cela — le plus rentable. Penseur
hédoniste et athée, il s’érige depuis ces
dernières années en défenseur du peuple,
ce qui lui vaut parfois d’être rangé parmi les
populistes. Dans son œuvre (très abondante),
je retiens sa Conte-histoire de la philosophie,
son Traité d'athéologie, une critique argumentée
et intéressante des religions ; et enfin son
pamphlet contre Freud qui a fait grand bruit,
Le Crépuscule d'une idole.
Voici maintenant les philosophes
vivants les plus importants à l’international :
* Noam Chomsky (né en 1928) est peut-être le père
de la linguistique moderne avec sa théorie de
la grammaire universelle. Dans un second temps,
il est devenu un philosophe et un activiste
anarchiste — tout en étant professeur au
MIT — qui dénonce l’impérialisme,
le capitalisme, et les guerres. Il
a coécrit la référence moderne de l’analyse de
la propagande, La fabrication du consentement.
* Jürgen Habermas (né en 1929) est
un philosophe allemand, la figure de
proue de la seconde génération de l’École de
Francfort. Il est connu comme le promoteur de
l’éthique de la discussion : il fait l’éloge de
la « communication » comme moyen de parvenir à
un consensus démocratique dans sa Théorie de
l’agir communicationnel, qui est, en dépit
de la grande abstraction du propos, un des plus
importants ouvrages de sociologie du XXe siècle.
* Charles Taylor (né en 1931) est un philosophe
canadien. Il est connu comme le penseur du
communautarisme. À ses yeux, les individus ont
une responsabilité à l’égard des communautés
auxquelles ils appartiennent. Il explique qu’il
est difficile de se définir dans le monde moderne,
parce que l’identité est construite
par diverses couches qui peuvent se
contredire autant que se compléter.
* Peter Singer (né en 1946) est le
philosophe australien à l’origine de la « bible »
des défenseurs des animaux, La Libération animale.
Il combat le spécisme : toute discrimination
entre les espèces animales est arbitraire,
en vertu de quoi on ne peut pas considérer que
seule la vie humaine est sacrée. Il a créé le
scandale en expliquant que tuer un chimpanzé peut
être plus grave que tuer un être humain dont le
handicap mental le prive du statut de personne.
* Slavoj Zizek (né en 1949) est un philosophe
slovène marxiste influencé par les idées du
psychanalyste Jacques Lacan. Sa propension à
mélanger les disciplines intellectuelles
(philosophie, psychanalyse, théologie,
histoire, et théorie politique), la
littérature, la culture populaire,
et l’humour suscite la controverse. Il écrit
surtout sur la formation de l’identité dans
le monde post-moderne. Sa popularité hors du
monde académique et l’apparente incohérence
de ses idées lui valent la réputation
d’être une vedette dont le travail n’a
pas vocation à être pris au sérieux.
* Judith Butler (née en 1956) est une
philosophe américaine. Elle est la théoricienne de
référence de la théorie du genre. Elle affirme que
le genre est une construction culturelle liée
à la performativité du discours, ce qui rend
l’individu totalement libre de faire évoluer
comme bon lui semble son identité sexuelle.
Que reproche-t-on à la philosophie ?
Que reproche-t-on à la philosophie sur le fond ?
Je pense que la philosophie s’attire
3 principaux reproches sur le fond.
1° Elle pêche tout d’abord par dogmatisme.
En effet, les philosophes — certes pas
tous — tendent à affirmer des vérités de
manière péremptoire, comme s’il s’agissait
de vérités universelles, indubitables. Les
théories complètement fallacieuses sont donc
nombreuses dans l’histoire de la philosophe.
Platon affirme par exemple que la cité
idéale doit rassembler 5040 citoyens.
Mais comme je l’ai déjà dit, une partie des
philosophes sont au contraire des sceptiques,
qui dénoncent les prétentions des dogmatiques.
2° La philosophie pêche également par irréalisme.
Comme les philosophes — pas tous, encore une
fois — comme ils se consacrent à la pensée,
ils ont tendance à réduire le monde au monde
des idées. Dès lors, ils perdent le contact avec
la réalité ; leurs spéculations abstraites
n’ont plus de rapport avec la vie concrète
des hommes. La cité idéale décrite par Platon
dans La République apparaît par exemple comme
une utopie inapplicable dans le monde réel.
« Mettre le pied dans une classe de philosophie,
c’est se voir contraint d’entrer en relation
avec un univers complètement distinct de
celui qu’on a laissé derrière soi dans la
rue. » — William James, Le pragmatisme
Après, une partie des philosophes sont conscients
de ce problème. Certains considèrent qu’il
faut « tester expérimentalement » les idées
philosophiques comme les scientifiques mettent
à l’épreuve leurs théories, en recourant
systématiquement à des exemples concrets
et à des expériences de pensée.
3° Enfin, la philosophie
pêche également par idéologie.
C’est Marx qui a donné de l’ampleur à ce reproche.
Il affirme dans L’idéologie allemande que les
théories philosophiques fait partie des fausses
représentations produites par les dominants pour
légitimer l’exploitation des dominés. À ses yeux,
ces théories dissimulent subtilement la manière
dont les évolutions de la vie matérielle,
et non pas intellectuelle, déterminent
les rapports de force dans la société.
« Les pensées de la classe dominante sont
aussi, à toutes les époques, les pensées
dominantes. » — Karl Marx, L’idéologie allemande
Le marxisme prétend sortir de l’idéologie en
incorporant une réflexion économique,
car dans sa perspective matérialiste,
l’évolution des moyens de production est le
facteur essentiel de la réalité objective.
Que reproche-t-on à la philosophie sur la forme ?
Je vois bien comment les gens réagissent lorsque
je leur dis que j’écris à propos d’idées
philosophiques. Leur moue veut dire : « il
explique avec des mots super compliqués des
choses que personne ne comprend ». Ce n’est
pas très agréable pour moi, mais je pense que ce
n’est pas un préjugé — le reproche est légitime.
À vrai dire, il est si banal que le verbe «
philosopher » signifie, par extension, discourir
de manière pédante sur des subtilités inutiles.
Nous pensons souvent, à cet égard, aux livres
allemands du XIXe siècle, mais le reproche est
aussi ancien que la philosophie. Dès l’Antiquité,
les philosophes ont tendance à exprimer leurs
idées de manière compliquée. Lorsque Platon
donne des cours publics, par exemple, sa renommée
attire une foule nombreuse ; mais les gens fuient
progressivement, rebutés par l’abstraction du
propos. À l’époque romaine, Sénèque accuse les
philosophes professionnels de chercher la
gloire par la virtuosité de leur langue.
Le penchant pour l’obscurité se perpétue dans
l’histoire de la philosophie. Au Moyen Âge,
la philosophie scolastique se perd dans
une abstraction et un formalisme excessifs,
au point que l’adjectif « scolastique » prend
une connotation péjorative. Au XIXe siècle,
les philosophes allemands, dans la lignée
de Hegel, atteignent des sommets en termes
d’obscurité. Mais les philosophes postmodernes de
la seconde moitié du XXe siècle perpétueront la
tradition en transposant abusivement les concepts
et la terminologie des sciences exactes dans les
sciences humaines.
«
Le succès de Hegel marqua le début de l’« âge de
la malhonnêteté », selon l’expression utilisée
par Schopenhauer pour désigner l’époque de
l’idéalisme allemand [...] C’est l’ère des
formules ronflantes et du verbiage prétentieux. »
— Karl Popper, La société ouverte et ses ennemis
Pourquoi les philosophes ne
s’expriment-ils pas clairement ?
Je pense qu’il y a 2 raisons principales :
1. La quête du statut. Employer des mots
techniques est un moyen de produire
artificiellement de l’autorité
intellectuelle. En effet, l’usage d’un terme
particulièrement savant suppose implicitement
la maîtrise d’idées complexes, et donc un certain
niveau d’intelligence. Les mots sont à cet égard,
comme les possessions matérielles, des signes
du statut social. Comme le lui reproche Sénèque,
le philosophe recherche la gloire.
2. La logique de l’initiation. Employer des mots
techniques, c’est aussi une manière de séparer
les profanes et les initiés. Comprenne qui pourra.
Dans les écoles de l’Antiquité, les maîtres
tiennent parfois des discours différents pour
le public et pour leurs élèves. Tout le monde peut
entendre les discours dits « exotériques » ; mais
seuls les initiés méritent d’entendre les
discours dits « ésotériques ».
Alors,
la vidéo
vous a plu ?
J’espère que oui.
Je vous rappelle
que c’est un extrait
de ma formation de culture générale
« Culture Express ».
Si vous voulez en savoir plus,
cliquez sur le lien
qui apparaît maintenant
en haut à droite de la vidéo,
ou bien
sur celui qui est dans la description
de cette vidéo.
Voilà voilà,
comme d’habitude
n’hésitez pas à m’écrire
dans les commentaires,
et puis SURTOUT
N’OUBLIEZ PAS
que vous n’avez PAS BESOIN
de vous prendre la tête
pour vous cultiver.